the Star Wars universe is vast and
infinitely rich in lore with just about
every minor background character having
their own book action figure and fanfic
page it can all get a bit overwhelming
for the average fan which is why we put
together this quick guide to some of the
new rogue 1 characters with more meaning
than you realize
Vivek while you're toasting the
destruction of the Death Star stop at 4
out of 44 for tipic if you don't
recognize the name Tiffin is the rebel
informant who passes word to casseon
and/or about Bodie secret message and/or
repays civic by killing it it's a
surprisingly dark move for a member of
the heroic Rebel Alliance which in
previous films have been painted as the
white knights of the galaxy Cathi ins
ruthless decision to kill tipic in order
to ensure the secrecy of his mission
paints the Alliance and a far more
morally ambiguous life and sets the tone
for the entire film by letting the
audience know right away that this isn't
your parents shiny happy rebellion with
both the plot and the tone of the movie
turning on typic because one short scene
holds an unusual amount of meeting we
keep see you be this guy has very little
backstory so far but we seek to you be
presence among sauger eras partisans
speaks to the variety of the Empire's
misdeeds if this little murder-happy
piranha looking dude hates the empire
enough to fight kill and die on the side
of the rebels then the Empire might want
to consider re-evaluating its outreach
policy given what we know of the Ewok
future role in bringing down the Empire
it would seem that the enviros policies
either discriminate against or simply
don't a counter a vertically challenged
species and that's not the only
connection between we teeth and the
Ewoks we teeth was played by Warwick
Davis who also played wicked in Return
of the Jedi
these are Fortuna related to Jabba the
Hutt right-hand man bib Fortuna Caesar
is another member of the partisan the
fate of Beezer who was seen briefly at
saw Guerrero's hideout on Jetta is
unclear but his connection to bib
Fortuna speaks to saw Guerrero's
willingness to work with the criminal
underworld to bring down the Empire too
bad we didn't get to see the two Fortuna
settle their ideological differences
through a desert dance-off
kay x-series security droid the KX
serious security droid is a product line
of a racket industries a company whose
connection to the Galactic Empire runs
deep the KX series clearly has some
serious security issues which allowed
can see an Android or reprogram k2s o to
the good side I'll do that for you the
captain said I had to despite this
though a racket industries remains
partnered with the Empire throughout the
original trilogy they're the folks
responsible for the iconic viper probe
droids that hunt down Luke Skywalker and
Han Solo and the ice planet hoth and the
Empire Strikes Back why would the Empire
keep working with a company which makes
dangerously shoddy droids that can
easily be hacked or taken out with one
shot
probably because Grand Moff Tarkin and
advertently destroyed evidence that
their droids vulnerabilities when he
blew up scarran base whoops thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to